doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs mit peter wermuth am
rand von charkiw der zweitgrößten stadt
der ukraine
hier liegt eine seiner lage häuser für
kaffeebohnen und kaffeemaschinen
vor über 20 jahren stürzte sich der
schweizer wagemutig in sein ukrainisches
abenteuer pur harrison ist im letzten
april dafür sage zu dass ich gute presse
wie geht es ihnen gut sie zu tun
manche nennen ihn den kaffee könig der
ukraine
denn peter wer mut hat ein café imperium
aufgebaut dass hier alle kennen
geht es nach abpfiff er ist einer der
wenigen schweizer privatunternehmer hier
als zu unsicher gilt die ukraine als zu
korrupt
was hat denn das duo für sie bedeutet im
april wurde der polizei eine toilette
natürlich sehr freuen
die warme halle überzeugen
250 kunden das sind gleich per live
das ist eigentlich so einfach gut 30
vorschläge was kostet die gleichzeitig
heißen ist da hier in graz faust durch
zeitig passiert tribüne gebrochen
außer in hohne computer genau zuordnen
um die private hunderttausend dollar
nahmen die steuerfahnder im april 2015
mit und steckten sie in ihre eigenen
taschen
doch diesmal ließ peter wermuth sich das
nicht bieten und ging vor gericht
es entschied zu seinen gunsten aber
gelöst wurde der fall auf ukrainisch sie
brachten das geld zurück namen ist aber
gleich wieder mit aber das geld aber
wenn auf der 12
wir mussten es nachträglich machen wir
das positive problem gefördert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
goldener herbst in kiew man feiert den
neuen vatertag auf dem majdan dem platz
der unabhängigkeit
fast nichts erinnert daran dass hier vor
kurzem hunderttausende für reformen
demonstrierten und dass das land vom
krieg zerrissen ist
einzig an diesem stand sammelt man geld
für die freiwilligen an der front
[Musik]
so heiter hatte ich mir die stimmung
nicht vorgestellt
[Musik]
die
die ukraine grenzland zwischen ost und
west 15 mal so groß wie die schweiz 45
millionen einwohner
ich bin in kiew das umkämpfte
konfliktgebiet um den jetzt liegt rund
700 kilometer im osten und dahinter
russland
der übermächtige nachbar
in der sowjetunion wurde die
freundschaft zwischen den beiden völkern
verherrlicht
[Musik]
hand in hand schreiten der russe und der
ukraine in eine gemeinsame lichte
zukunft
doch das war einmal
in diesem film möchte ich herausfinden
wie kam es dazu dass die sogenannten
bruder völker sich derart in zweiten
hier in kiew scheint der krieg weit weg
und doch findet er noch immer statt
wie aber lebt es sich in diesem
zerrissenen land
ein besuch steht mir bevor bei der
kinderärztin zettler nabis bei lofer
einer alten bekannten
[Musik]
wir lernten uns während einer reportage
kennen
das war 1992 damals wusste man fast
nichts über die ukraine
sie war ein weißer fleck auf der
landkarte hatte eben ihre unabhängigkeit
erklärt zuvor war sie jahrzehntelang
teil der sowjetischen welt gewesen
[Musik]
anfang der 90er jahre war ich das erste
mal beim atomkraftwerk tschernobyl
ein alptraum bis heute
[Musik]
svetlana war damals kinderärztin
wir trafen sie in einer kinderklinik wo
sie die spezialabteilung für kinder von
tschernobyl leitet dort untersuchte sie
die gesundheitlichen folgen der
atomkatastrophe
es zeigte sich der schilddrüsen krebs
bei kindern und jugendlichen nahm hier
in den ersten zehn jahren nach dem
akw-unfall ums zehnfache zu svetlana
hatte den horror selbst miterlebt sie
wohnte 1986 in pripjat der stadt neben
dem akw nach der explosion des reaktors
wurde sie mit ihrem mann der kleinen
tochter und tausenden anderen in diesen
außenbezirk von kiew evakuiert man sagte
ihnen damals sei nur für wenige tage
doch 1992 lebte sie noch immer hier
[Musik]
heute über 20 jahre später will ich die
kinderärztin svitlana wieder besuch sie
wohnt mit ihrem mann immer noch an
derselben adresse in einer kleinen
zweizimmerwohnung mehr ist als sei die
zeit hier still gestanden
[Musik]
auch der aufzug ist der alte ich bin
gespannt auf sap hana möchte von
erfahren wie sie die schon so vieles
durchgemacht hat die jetzige krise ihres
landes erlebt
[Musik]
über 20 jahre sind wir uns nicht mehr
begegnet es wird klar so lange haben wir
uns nicht gesehen sie auf eine neue
frisur
ja sie auch kommen sie rein so viele
jahre sind vergangen wie geht es ihnen
ja viele jahre
es geht uns ja gut schauen sie wie groß
julia geworden ist junge frau sie haben
doch davon geträumt in eine andere
wohnung zu ziehen
das weiß ich gar nicht mehr aber
natürlich möchten wir das immer noch bis
jetzt hat es leider nicht getan
wegen der wirtschaftskrise ja auch das
bauwesen steckt in einer schrecklichen
krise die wohnungen werden immer teurer
aber nicht fertig gebracht
es gibt viele bauruinen deshalb haben
wir etwas pech
und jetzt der ganze krieg das ganze land
leidet krieg kostet wie immer geld in
der ost ukraine leiden aber wir alle
auch das einfache volk empfindet so wir
tun uns alle leid aber wir können ja
nicht helfen
[Musik]
svetlana erzählt mir ihre geschichte sie
und ihr mann investierten in den bau
einer eigentumswohnung wurden aber
zusammen mit vielen anderen von einem
spekulanten um ihr ganzes erspartes
betrogen ihre wohnung blieb eine
bauruine
gemeinsam gingen sie vor gericht
bis jetzt erfolglos und so hat die
kinderärztin aufgehört auf eine neue
wohnung zu hoffen
seit tschernobyl ist ihre gesundheit zu
dem und stabil
eigentlich wurde swetlana als sogenannte
tschernobyl invalide frühpensioniert
aber weil ihre rente noch 50 euro
beträgt muss sie weiter arbeiten
das maximum dass sie pro monat dazu
verdienen kann sind weitere 50 euro
fabriken wurden geschlossen
es gab entlassungen natürlich haben wir
seit dem krieg mehr arbeitslosigkeit
es ist für die menschen schwieriger
geworden zu überleben wegen der krise
begangen die preise zu steigen und da
wird eine arbeitslos das ist natürlich
hart zudem steigen die strompreise ein
elend kommt zum anderen
[Musik]
seit kriegsbeginn 2014 hat sich der
lebensstandard rapide verschlechtert die
wirtschaft liegt am boden
die löhne und renten sind minimal die
preise aber stiegen in den letzten zwei
jahren fast ums dreifache die
mittelschicht schrumpft es geht reiche
und superreiche aber breite schichten
leben jetzt in out
nehmen sie einen schokoladen bonbons sie
sind sehr gut von unseren präsidenten
poroschenko von seiner firma roche alle
sind von ihm die ganze stadt ist voll
von poroschenko leben
auch schokolade und torten kann man dort
kaufen in unserem quartier gibt es auch
einen solchen laden wir kaufen dort
orten
das heißt sein geschäft blüht
offensichtlich es gibt ja so viele leben
offiziell müsste er seinen schoko
business aufgeben andere übernahmen die
leitung aber alle wissen dass das noch
immer die schoko bonbons unseres
präsidenten sind und machen witze
julia war 14 als wir uns kennenlernten
sie hat wie ihre mutter einen
ukrainischen pass beide aber wurden in
russland geboren
zu sowjetzeiten noch vor der
unabhängigkeit damals war das kein
problem du konntest zusammensein mit wem
auch immer es war friedlich
niemand fragte danach hubmann russe
ukraine tartar oder mongole war das war
völlig egal
nach den ersten schießereien auf der
meydan aber vor allem nach der
abspaltung der krim
ab frühling 2014 wurden die messer
gewetzt die ansichten und gespräche
veränderten sich osten gegen westen
russen gegen ukraine
es gibt solche reibereien sie sprechen
russisch
empfinden sie sich als russe oder
ukrainerin schwer zu sagen
mir ist ich habe zwei heimaten
[Musik]
die planer und julia haben vier
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer russische
wurzeln
das ist nicht einfach in zeiten des
krieges zwischen den einstigen bruder
völkern
allerdings war russland immer der
größere bruder der in der ukraine das
sagen hatte
die katastrophe von tschernobyl hat das
leben von svetlana radikal verändert
tschernobyl zeigt aber auch exemplarisch
wie russland die ukraine behandelt
[Musik]
gebaut wurde das russische atomkraftwerk
von tschernobyl auf befehl der moskauer
parteizentrale in einem der schönsten
naturgebiete der damaligen ukrainischen
sowjetrepublik
es war ebenfalls die sowjetregierung in
moskau wie viel zu spät über das ausmaß
der nuklearen katastrophe informierte
und die bevölkerung zu spät evakuieren
ließ
[Musik]
1989 organisierten die ukrainischen
grünen eine erste großdemonstration in
kerth
[Musik]
es war ein unglaubliches ereignis 20.000
überwanden ihre angst vor repressionen
und nahmen teil der tschernobyl schock
verstärkte den lange unterdrückten
wunsch weg von russland weg von der
sowjetunion
[Musik]
wir verlassen und fahren richtung osten
die stadt charkiw
[Musik]
in die nähe des umkämpften gebietes in
charkiw treffe ich wieder den schweizer
peter wermuth der gelernte mechaniker
hat in der ukraine eine kaffeehauskette
mit heute über 100 filialen und rund
2500 angestellten aufgebaut
[Musik]
auch noch eine runde die meisten haben
noch nicht begriffen dass auch haben wir
die schöne schweiz verlag die sich für
die schweiz jedoch aus spenden bezahlt
worden
wem er eigentlich eine neue
herausforderung gesucht hat nur das
getan was die anderen machen
das ist einfach grund die nur nach
aufruf teile die fahne das team das vom
play die welt selbst bekenntnis zu
keiner bekräftige hier also häufig als
kandidatin oder so nach bewusst an die
masche der 60 kilometer zur grenze
wieder mal
die continental maschine hier das wahre
problem eines landes militär ist so
stark
obschon sie immer sicher nützlich das
ganze auslieferungs landgestüt rvs zeit
nach einer das aus mit tankstopp ist
nicht gut 1000 menschen sterben
der berner bauern gut machte mit dem
import von kaffeebohnen und
kaffeemaschinen in der ukraine eine
steile karriere
tierschützer zeit stück börsenbetreiber
medienträchtige probierte der kaffee
trinkt maschine hier wird das paket
diesem konzept ist kann man probieren
und jedes aroma testen ob das tatmesser
florida und machen sie uns bitte zwei
cappuccino 21 jahren ist natürlich eine
sehr jungen vergangen hatte das ist
immer der beste
nach der partie
die ganze die kapitalschnitt damit
bleibt der natürlich im moment ist
und vor allem wann hier mit dem krieg
und trotzdem csu muss wirklich auf das
land das waren zeigen bei den
schwierigkeiten finanziell revival
was für ein prozentsatz von denen 13
das ist was ich da hoffen könnte die
autonomie hüte sie hat viele junge
gestellt haben wegen der für praktische
nummer junge leute die sagen jetzt mal
von einem sowjetunion hospiz- und
hochwasser die sich für die hexe hat
jene brauchen die leute reden resultate
erzielen dabei sich einfacher sein
eine schlüsselrolle für peter wermuth
spielte damals wie heute tatjana parasit
seine ehemalige lebensgefährtin und
heutige geschäftspartnerin vor über 20
jahren hat peter das alles aufgebaut
das brauchte es damals für eigenschaften
um sich auf dem ukrainischen markt
durchzusetzen
peter ist einzigartig in der tat nicht
nur für die schweiz auch für die ukraine
er ist sehr offen und alles was er macht
liegt dass ihr könnt die menschen mit
seiner liebe seinem interesse an stecken
als er vor 20 jahren begann tranken alle
pulverkaffee niemand hatte damals den
bundes- oder dachte daran ein café
business aufzubauen daran glaubte
niemand die leute sagten wiese wo kaffee
versucht es doch lieber mit wodka oder
bier wer geht denn schon in eine bar
espresso trinken
in diesem hochhaus besitzt hat jana eine
große eigentumswohnung das
kaffeeunternehmen dass peter wermuth
gründete läuft immer noch gut auch wenn
der umsatz seit kriegsbeginn um fast die
hälfte eingebrochen ist
[Musik]
tatjana hat vier kinder adoptiert der
kaffee könig ist oft im ausland
unterwegs aber wenn er da ist wohnt er
bei der familie und kümmert sich um die
kinder geht der größte bestätigung noch
die kinder wachsen dreisprachig auf
hochdeutsch russisch mit tatiana und
jetzt auch ukrainisch in der schule wird
mehr ukrainisch gesprochen es gibt mehr
ukrainische schulen unsere kinder werden
ukraine sprechen
etwas positives habe der bewaffnete
konflikt in der ost ukraine bewirkt sagt
bei mir noch nie sei das ukrainische
nationalgefühl so stark gewesen wie
heute
die ukraine hat eine komplizierte
geschichte war nie ein eigener staat
immer spielball der nachbarländer vor
allem russlands erst als die sowjetunion
zerfiel wurde sie unabhängig in der
hauptstadt kiew aber blieb die neu
gewählte regierung korrupt und mit der
wirtschaft ging es bergab
2004 weckte die orange revolution
hoffnungen auf ein ende des korrupten
regimes vergehens die ukraine kam nicht
zur ruhe
ab november 2013 demonstrierten in kiew
hunderttausende gegen die korruption der
regierung janukowitsch und für europa
ihm wollte ich unbedingt kennenlernen
andrej kurkow den ukrainischen
schriftsteller er lebt mit seiner
familie ganz in der nähe des
marienplatzes hörte die schüsse in
seiner wohnung der euro bei dann
forderte über 100 tote
coalcorp hat die aufwühlenden monate in
der chronik ukrainisches tagebuch
festgehalten haben sich all die opfer
gelohnt
es hörte ja nicht auf nachdem euro mai
dann folgte die annexion der krim und
der krieg im don was der mann hat die
ukraine gerettet ohne meiden und hat
diese opfer wäre die ukraine ein zweites
weißrussland geworden
wir würden uns jetzt in der russischen
föderation auflösen
die ukrainische demokratie war die
langsam verschwinden und sie würden uns
ein einparteiensystem aufzwingen wie in
russland
[Musik]
andrej kurkow wurde in russland geboren
lebt aber seit seiner kindheit in kiew
seine romane wurden in über 30 sprachen
übersetzt seitdem euro meiden und den
krieg ist auch seine welt durcheinander
geraten
seit zwei jahren schreibe ich nur
artikel essays über die politische
situation
die beziehung zwischen russland und der
ukraine der krieg dauert nun schon weit
über ein jahr
wie alle beginne ich seither den tag
damit dass ich im internet schaue was in
der nacht geschehen ist und verfolge
dann die nachrichten
sie haben keine lust belletristik zu
schreiben
nein ich habe keine lust würde ich steht
er arische werke schreiben dann nur um
meine psyche zu beruhigen um in eine
fantasiewelt zu schlichten aus einer
wirklichkeit die ziemlich dramatisch ist
[Musik]
der krieg im donbass hat bisher über
9000 tote gefordert
russland hat in der ukraine aufgezwungen
seit frühling 2014 kämpfen dort
ukrainische separatisten unterstützt von
russischen verbänden
gegen die ukrainische armee und
ukrainische freiwillige die ukraine
krise sei eigentlich eine russische
krise sagt mirko kussin akzeptieren
nicht dass die ukraine ihren eigenen weg
nach westen gehen will und er fürchte
ein überschwappen des freiheits wunsches
nach russland
[Musik]
dass sich ausgerechnet in kohle und
industriegebiet des donners viele
menschen russland anschließen möchten
hat auch historische gründe
schon unter den zaren und der späteren
sowjetunion lebten und arbeiteten viele
russen in der ost ukraine die kumpels
hatten ihren proletarischen stolz sie
galten als helden der arbeit in der 90er
jahren brach die kohleförderung im don
was fast um die hälfte ein
die region verloren bedeutung vieler ost
ukraine verherrlicht deshalb die alten
sowjet-zeiten sie misstrauen der
regierung in kiew und fühlen sich im
stich gelassen
[Musik]
wie hat sich denn nun die situation im
donbass entwickeln die menschen dort
verstehen dass sie in einer katastrophe
geraten sind
sie hofften dass russland sie aufnehmen
würde russland kabinen waffen humanitäre
hilfe gilt die renten kriegen sie dort
in ruhe die ganze und versuchen nun eine
doppelte rente auch noch eine von der
ukraine zu kriegen aber die ukraine
braucht den bass jetzt auch nicht
wirklich nur für die ganzheit des landes
im prinzip ist das eine zerstörte region
in die man milliarden dollar investieren
muss russland wird das nicht tun weil
russland den dom was auch nicht braucht
in der ost ukraine wurden auch zehn
cafés von peter wermuth kaffeehauskette
zerstört oder beschlossen jetzt besucht
der patron eine mitarbeiterin die der
krieg vertrieben hat mit seiner hand hat
janas hilfe hat anja vor kurzem in kiew
einen coffee shop eröffnet wie geht es
ihnen sehr angenehm
ihr wart doch auch im donners ich
erinnere mich ihr kapuziner schön danke
das ist der konzertsaal im zentrum
so sieht er jetzt aus
[Musik]
das fußballstadion
ja das war eines der besten stadien der
ukraine
hier ist der eingang und da rechts war
unser café port unmöglich
nur wegen der politik das ist im zentrum
der kultur
[Musik]
meine freunde haben denn jetzt auch
verlassen
es war sinnlos dort zu bleiben alle
jungen menschen mit einer höheren
ausbildung die ganze intelligenz die
ganze mittelklasse alle kmu sind weg man
sieht dort keine entwicklungs keine
lebensperspektive
es ist ein gesetz loses gebiet ohne
zukunft der krieg ist sinnlos aber nicht
alle denken so sie haben von ihrer
großmutter erzählt meine großmutter ist
für russland viele menschen aus dem
gebiet von don jetzt haben russische
verwandte ein teil der familie ist
russisch deshalb können sie einfach
nicht glauben dass russland in der
ukraine als aggressor auftreten kann
der krieg in zweite familie ja es gab
momente wo wir überhaupt nicht mehr mit
unseren verwandten und freunden sprachen
ein teil unserer familie war für
russland ein teil für die ukraine
doch am ende muss man ja die familien
erhalten nicht die politik ist das
wichtigste auf der welt sondern die
familie und die liebe
[Musik]
ach ukraine geht es mir immer wieder
durch den kopf der krieg im osten
entzweit nicht nur regionen sondern
ganze familien zerstört freundschaften
und treibt einen keil zwischen die alte
und die junge generation
so schön ist dieses land so viel leid
muss und musste es immer wieder ertragen
wie die schreckliche hungersnot von 1932
sie ist bei uns weitgehend unbekannt sie
traf vor allem die bauern eine weitere
unzählige verstrickung mit russland mit
einer langen vorgeschichte über 100
jahre gehörten weite teile der heutigen
ukraine zum zarenreich alles ukrainische
wurde brutal unterdrückt nach der
russischen revolution von 1917 folgte
eine kurze periode der ukrainischen
freiheit 1922 dann wurden weite gebiete
der heutigen ukraine in die sowjetunion
eingegliedert
noch blickt das recht auf nationale
selbstbestimmung geduldet
stalins aufstieg aber machte der
relativen unabhängigkeit ein ende
die alleinige macht lag nun bei der
parteizentrale in moskau stalins terror
herrschaft begann ab ende der 20er jahre
wurden tausende ukrainische
oppositionelle wegen nationalistischer
tendenzen deportiert oder umgebracht
[Musik]
der nächste schlag traf besonders die
kornkammer ukraine stalin befahl die
enteignung der bauern und die
kollektivierung der landwirtschaft
viele bauern leisteten passiven
widerstand verbrannten ihre ernte und
töteten evi 1932 lag die landwirtschaft
im chaos
[Musik]
stalin schickte über 100.000 rotarmisten
in die ukraine
sie sollten die ernte überwachen noch
hätte die ernte das ukrainische volk
ernähren können stalin aber exportierter
kaltblütig weizen in den westen
wenn er sie nicht absichtlich
herbeiführte so hat stalin die folgende
schreckliche hungersnot somit ist brutal
in kauf genommen und den ukrainischen
nationalismus zu brechen
[Musik]
insgesamt starben bei der großen
hungersnot von 1932 33 über drei
millionen menschen ein nationales trauma
bis heute
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs richtung tschernobyl
ich fahre mit der kinderärztin svitlana
zu ihrer alten wohnung in der stadt
triberg neben dem akw
sie liegt in der sperrzone svitlana war
seit der katastrophe vor 30 jahren nie
mehr da
für die verseuchte zone brauchen wir
eine spezial genehmigung
das auto dürfen wir nur an bestimmten
stellen verlassen es strahlt hier
überall aber nicht überall gleich stark
dort wo es unsere begleiterin erlaubt
können wir ein paar stunden bleiben ohne
dass es uns gefährdet
[Musik]
gab es hier früher eine straße natürlich
eine große breite ebene straße es gab
keine bäume von hier aus samen fast die
ganze stadt
aber jetzt weiß ich gar nicht wo wir
hier sind
[Musik]
das hier ist die post dann eben die
schule rechts die post
früher war es hier so lebendig viele
schulkinder kamen hierher zum
schwimmunterricht die sport sektion
trainierten hier
es gab wettkämpfe sogar internationale
mit sportlern von überall hier waren
immer viele leute ich weiß noch nicht
einmal ob ich traurig bin es ist ein
eigenartiges gefühl als ob alles weit
weg wäre
rundherum ist alles grün als ob es
draußen leben geben aber hier alles leer
schrecklich
hierfür ist
[Musik]
dort der dritte von oben das ist unser
balkon
wieviel 0,35 mikrogramm pro stunde fast
normal
ja das ist unsere wohnung
ich habe mich nicht getäuscht
sogar die tapeten sie mutter was war
hier das war das kinderzimmer von julia
da klebt noch ein kätzchen oder so was
von ihr was war damals das schlimmste
[Musik]
hier war alles gut wir waren jung die
stadt war wunderschön wie geschaffen für
uns junge wir hatten ein so erfülltes
leben
alles endete so plötzlich in einem
einzigen moment ich habe sehr oft davon
geträumt dass ich nach hause kommen
schon von weitem sah ich durchs fenster
die lampe brennen
ich habe diese wohnung nie vergessen
50.000 vor allem junge menschen wohnten
wie swetlana in blieb j die meisten
arbeiteten im und um das atomkraftwerk
leben wird in dieser geisterstadt nehme
möglich sein
[Musik]
ist dies an land das immer leidet ich
finde es natürlich traurig dass unsere
ukraine immer leidet wir können einfach
den weg nicht finden der uns zu einem
besseren leben führen würde
und das möchten wir ja alle wir hoffen
alle sehr dass der krieg möglichst bald
beendet wird
dann wird es vielleicht besser werden
aber wir sind wohl an dieser krise bis
zu einem gewissen grad selber schuld
unsere wirtschaft ist nicht gut
entwickelt zudem ist die korruption bei
uns sehr stark entwickelt aber sie haben
ihren optimismus nicht verloren
vielleicht bin ich ein solcher mensch
etwas optimistisch es hat sich in mir
erhalten
denn wenn wir beginnen den optimismus zu
verlieren was wird dann aus uns
faulenzer schlafmützen wir nichts
aufbauen und zustande bringen
man darf den optimismus nicht verlieren
[Musik]
welches ist denn ihrer meinung nach
heute das größte problem der ukraine in
der ukraine bis in den letzten 25 jahren
ein hauptproblem
wenn sie total ist verlieren die
menschen den ort zu arbeiten etwas zu
erreichen wenn sie sehen dass ehrlich
geldverdienen unmöglich ist dass man
teil des korrupten systems werden muss
da verlieren sie immer
bei jenen die ehrlich und anständig
bleiben wollen kommt so der wunsch auf
zu emigrieren ins ausland oder in die
innere emigration sich mit kunst
befassen lesen buddhismus yoga einfach
etwas tun wohin die macht der korruption
nicht hinreicht
[Musik]
das haben wir nicht erwartet
peter wermut und ich tauchen ein in eine
surreale welt ins luxus anwesen des nach
russland geflüchteten ex präsidenten
viktor janukowitsch
faszinierend auch für brautpaare sein
einst scharf bewacht des 130 hektar
großes gelände war kiew ist nun
öffentlich so etwas wie ein korruptions
museum ein symbol für die maßlose
selbstbereicherung des vertriebenen
machthabers seine 50 zimmer residenz
wunderbare parkanlagen ein privat so ein
golfplatz alles exklusiv für die
banditen bande von viktor janukowitsch
sagt der museumsführer und hier ist sein
privates zimmer wir sein familienwappen
das ließ er wohl anfertigen oder kaufte
es und hier seine diversen porträts aus
verschiedenen materialien
dieses ist gemalt dieses aus salzkörner
gefertigt
dieses aus bernstein mit halbedelsteinen
verziert dieses gesteckt
und hier haben wir mohnsamen und
verschiedene getreidekörner die
unterhalts gelder für residenz und park
beliefen sich auf 4 millionen euro pro
monat
hier lebte der ex präsident in saus und
braus
während die ukraine auf den
staatsbankrott zusteuerte viktor
janukowitsch verantwortete ein
korruptions netz dass fast alle ebenen
des staates und der gesellschaft durch
drang seine regierung soll in seinen
vier amtsjahren milliarden von dollar
mit mafiamethoden außer landes geschafft
haben
[Musik]
entziehen sich 20 jahren im würgegriff
von korruption getrunken und durchlebt
dazu warum blieben sie ja ich kann nicht
einfach die medien zwei ob du sie glüht
war mit diesem system schaffe abstimmung
die mir den verein moralische pflicht
gegenüber der nyt das ist ja da war nie
gesetzt hey you durch die halo ich habe
bisher nur dank für die zu dem mono und
trotz dann das immer wieder abkassiert
werte und das ist hier hat das gericht
keine augenscheinlich praktisch für jede
verspricht zwar etwa 100 euro im jahr
ohne hre auslösen
wir sind über einen sockel leiter der
beste platz der schönsten orte der
dürfte note
und wie das funktioniert er ja dass mich
ist das ein beruf
hat denn all dies was war unter
janukowitsch der bevölkerung die augen
geöffnet wird sich etwas ändern
natürlich ich denke dass die mehrheit
der bevölkerung aufgewacht ist und in
einem anderen land leben werden
sie schämen sich dass sie in einer
solchen ukraine lebt und diese scham
versteht auch die neue regierung
selbst wenn sich einer von ihnen
bereichern möchte obwohl alle schon
reich sind werden sie nicht so
unverschämt skrupellos und zynisch
vorgehen wie janukowitsch und seine
regierungsmitglieder
nur zu gerne möchte ich andrej kurkow
optimismus teilen aber am ende meines
aufenthalts scheint mehr die ukraine
schwankt zwischen aufbruch und absturz
der selbstbestimmte weg nach westen und
das ende von krieg und korruption liegen
wohl noch in weiter ferne
[Musik]
ein anfang aber ist gemacht im
spätherbst 2015 treffen wir auf dem
majdan zufällig auf junge polizistin die
den kern einer neuen nicht korrupten
polizei bilden sollen
ein reformer volk der regierung von
präsident otto schenk
[Musik]
trotz neuer politischer turbulenzen ein
hoffnungsschimmer für die ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer
immerhin
[Musik]
wir machen
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz